Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy. My
name is David Flanagan, although you probably know
me as Rawkode.
And today, we're kicking off our new course,
the complete guide to Fermion Spin.
If you're not familiar, Spin is a framework
from the team at Fermion,
which allows you to write micro service applications
with a compilation target
of WebAssembly.
Now before we dive in to the different
SDKs and languages that you can write and
compile to WebAssembly web,
we're gonna spend a little bit of time
today understanding the why
of WebAssembly.
Why if you are a Rust developer,
TypeScript developer, Go developer, or any other developer,
should you care about using WebAssembly as a
target for your application?
And there are a few reasons.
And I hope that today's small demo
will set off a small chain reaction in
your mind
with an explosion of ideas
for your use case on WebAssembly.
So without further ado, let's dive in and
take a look at today's small code example
and why you should start looking at WebAssembly.
Let's dive right in.
So in order to show you why I
think WebAssembly is so important,
I have put together a small sample application.
Now the first thing to note is this
is not a life changing application.
This is not a production application.
This is a contrived example
that wants to show you how to consume
WebAssembly modules
across disparate systems.
Because the true value in WebAssembly comes from
the fact that we can choose to use
Rust for one part of our system,
Go in another,
JavaScript or TypeScript,
and so forth.
Now assuming you compile those to a WebAssembly
module,
they can be consumed
by a WebAssembly runtime or by other languages
that understand WebAssembly.
This means you get the ability to explore
and test new languages.
Use the correct language for the correct job.
Maybe the Rust is the right 190% of
the time, but there's still 10% where you
wanna fall back on JavaScript or Tensor.
There are times you want to use a
strongly typed language on the front end, like
Rust.
And these are all possible via the power
of WebAssembly.
In fact, Solomon Hicks,
the founder of Docker,
once said that if WebAssembly had existed,
Docker wouldn't.
He's saying that if WebAssembly
was a compilation target for applications,
we wouldn't need containers.
And that's a very powerful statement.
So let's dive into the contrived example
and see what I put together.
Okay.
First, we have the domain folder.
This is where we store the domain logic
for our application.
This is really common across most software teams
these days. Domain driven design has gathered a
lot of adoption
along with the various architectures which have spun
out of the movement.
It teaches us to build reusable components across
our domain using our domain language
and hopefully ensuring that you don't reimplement the
same thing twice.
This is often a challenge for companies that
want to have polyglot teams
because if you write your domain logic in
one language, how do you share it and
consume it in another?
This often leads to rather special test cases
to ensure that we have compliance
across multiple run times.
But with WebAssembly,
that concern disappears.
And I'm taking the domain that is hopefully
familiar to everybody watching this video.
Password validation.
Is the password that your customer or user
using
pass the constraints provided by your security team
across all of your applications?
So I've chosen to write this in Rust.
We have a constant defining the minimum length
for a password with 16 characters.
We have two error messages, password too short
and password no space, which give us the
error message if the password is too short
or has no space.
We then have a validate password function. Now
I kept this really small and simple for
today's demo,
but you may have more rules in your
production systems.
We receive the password,
and we return a result
or an error message.
If the length of the password is less
than password min length, we return an error
message.
And if it doesn't contain a space, we
return an error message.
Assuming both our constraints pass, we return our
okay response.
If we scroll down, you'll see we have
a test case.
I'm not gonna go through it, but it's
just making a few assertions against our function.
What's important here is that there is nothing
to tell you this is going to be
used on WebAssembly.
This is a Rust function using Rust types
and Rust paradigms.
This is the perfect example
of writing your domain logic
without truly understanding where it's going to end
up or be used.
Next, we have the Wasm crate.
This is our glue. This is what consumes
our domain logic
with a little bit of binding
to the WebAssembly module.
Now this first function is entirely optional,
but I wanna use it to show you
the interrupt between client side browser
and Rust.
Here, we're defining a function called main,
and we bind it using wasm bindgen to
run when our application has started.
We find the HTML DOM window,
the document,
and the body element.
From there,
we can actually write hello in your browser
and your browser.
Kinda neat.
Next, we want to expose our domain logic
via the Wasm bindings.
So we write a function
that calls our domain function.
Here we have wasm bindgen
validate password, which takes the string and returns
a result
or a JS value
error.
Next, we can just call our Rust function,
the validate password function, passing in our password.
Now because our domain logic returns a string
error,
we do need to map this to a
JS value.
And we do so like this.
Rust provides a map error function,
which takes the original value
and returns a different value.
Nice and simple.
From here,
we can compile our Wasm create,
and we have two pieces of reusable information.
Any other Rust service or application that we
build can consume our domain create just as
if it was another Rust create because it
is just another Rust create.
And any application that runs or supports WebAssembly
can pull in our WebAssembly module,
which just so happens to consume some of
our domain logic.
And you can expand on this as much
as you need and share as much of
that agnostic domain logic as you need across
all of your services.
So let's consume
our domain logic from a Fermion Spin application.
I've chosen to write this in Rust so
that we can see the Rust and Rust
interrupt.
Although, I should definitely point out that Fermion
Spin applications are compiled to a WebAssembly module.
Because of that and because our domain is
written in Rust, we don't need to consume
our domain logic as a WebAssembly module. We
can consume it as a Rust module, which
is still gonna be compiled to a WebAssembly
target.
Pretty cool.
Here we have
a macro that sets up our back end
function as an HTTP component on Fermion Spin
framework.
This just means that when request come in,
they can be routed to this back end
function.
And you'll see it takes a request input
parameter.
And all it expects is a result response.
Now we've got a little bit of tape
juggling to do to fetch the body from
this request,
but we can grab the base,
coerce it into a string,
and then call a validate password
function.
If we get an okay response, we return
a 200 okay. And if we get an
error message, we return a four zero one
with the error message.
Now let me click through to our validate
function.
This is
our nonspecific,
non WebAssembly knowledge,
straight up pure Rust
function.
So let's run our back end service.
So let's run spin build,
followed by spin up
and follow all to get the logs.
Now I provide a small HARL test suite,
which we can run
like so.
You'll see that two requests were made against
our back end API
and both succeeded.
What does our HARL test suite look like?
One, we send a post request to local
host 3,000
and the password is the full string and
the code block. Password space one two three
space password space one two three.
This will satisfy both our constraints.
One, that it's at least 16 characters and
two, that has at least one space.
Our second assertion is another post to localhost:one
And this time the password is password space.
So we pass the space constraint,
but not the 16
characters.
And this should return
a photo one.
And we can confirm by running Hurl one
more time.
Remove the dash dash test, and we will
get the output from the function or the
assertion that fails.
And the error message is the password must
contain at least 16 characters.
Perfect.
And for the last demo,
I'm going to consume the wasm trait. This
is a domain logic compiled and exposed via
WebAssembly.
This time being consumed by a JavaScript function.
Here,
with the right webpack configuration,
you can just pull in a WASM package.
So here, we're importing a WASM package like
any other Node JS dependency.
We use a promise so that after the
module is loaded, we call the validate password
function, and we pass it a password. In
this case,
password.
So now we can run this front end
application
and see it work.
We can run NPM,
run build,
followed by NPM,
run start.
This runs the webpack dev server,
which we can browse to in our browser.
So let's pop open
80 80.
And first, we see the string from our
Rust
compiled WebAssembly application.
If we take a look at index.HTML,
We actually don't
print out anything in the body of our
HTML.
So only by browsing to this
is the hello in your browser injected.
So let's pop open our dev tools.
And if we go to the console, you'll
see
that the password must be at least 16
characters.
Now I am no front end web developer.
To me, a good UI is in the
CLI.
However, we wanna show a demo today.
So we're gonna go back to our application
and modify the JavaScript code.
And this time, I'll make sure the password
passes
the constraints
and hit save.
Now the webpack web dev server will have
reloaded our application in the background, which internal
have reloaded
our browser.
And already, we can see the error message
about our password constraints is gone.
And one more time, we'll make it fail,
hit save, and jump back,
and the reload we caught just in time.
So from our front end application
and pure JavaScript,
we're able to consume our domain logic written
in Rust,
which is compiled to WebAssembly.
And that is the power of WebAssembly.
And that's all we're gonna cover in this
first video. I hope this piques your interest
in WebAssembly and you want to learn more.
In future segments of this course, we'll be
taking a look at all the SDKs provided
by Spin.
That is Rust,
TypeScript and JavaScript,
and Go.
We may even get a sneak preview
of the new Python SDK.
I'm not even sure if I'm allowed to
say that.
After we have covered the SDKs, we're going
to build some real world applications using Fermion
Spin. One, a Google Analytics replacement.
Not completely, but enough to get analytics from
the front end application stored into a database
on the back end.
This should show us what a full three
tier application looks like in the real world.
And because we're deploying it as web assembly
on Fermion Cloud,
we get almost infinite scale
with sub millisecond startup times for was in
binaries.
And the second application we will build
is an uptime checker.
Using WebAssembly,
we can make HTTP requests to check the
status of our website. We can run this
on a regular cadence
and send notifications
if our website fails to check.
So I hope you'll join us for the
next parts of this complete guide to Fermion
Spin.
Until then, I'll see you next time.
Have a great day.